a friend of mine a mutual friend of us
actually another comic went to see your
show in Edinburgh and he messaged me
after going I think Tom's had enough of
this [ __ ] and I don't know what [ __ ] he
was talking about exactly but I was
curious I I threw out every rule in the
book is what what I've done I've just I
got tired of listening to
people going well you can't punch up and
you can't punch down and you know that's
a hack premise or that's a dick joke or
whatever you're living in a room in a in
a world where there's now rules of
Comedy which comedy was there to break
all those rules do you know what I mean
and and we've just gotten so far to to
what you can say and what you can't say
we've been dying out on caviar every
[ __ ] day lately I want a McDonald's
burger you know what I mean I'm getting
tired of the snails man it's just a
[ __ ] comedy show you know what I mean
like [ __ ] if you don't like them
don't go and [ __ ] see them how about
that man but you're right now for you
you don't like a comedy show oh my God
here comes a Facebook post here comes uh
block I gotta block you now I gotta do
all of that sort of TripAdvisor
TripAdvisor four-star commit three and a
half star comedian I'm just gone to the
point well you know what I'm gonna take
everything Everybody's scared of saying
and I'm gonna Chuck it right in the face
hey Francis do you like entrepreneurs
not really what do you mean what do you
think would do a trigonometry annoy
people on the internet cause meltdowns
on Twitter and Destroy people with logic
and facts all right stop stealing my
catchphrases it's facts and logic I'm
just saying being an entrepreneur is
against my culture why would I work hard
when I could just rely on the beach in a
sombrero shouting
well for those of you who aren't
Venezuelan you need to check out Rob
Moore the disruptive entrepreneur Rob
Moore has been an entrepreneur for 16
years he's built seven companies written
18 business and investing books and now
he helps creators start up scale-ups and
anyone wanting to build assets income
and freedom for information education
and inspiration Rob has reached millions
of people to be disruptive entrepreneurs
and turn their passion into their
profession as well as instant access to
Rob's number one ranked disruptors
podcast with the world's most disruptive
guests and billionaires he's also giving
away a digital Financial toolkit to help
you save half your salary and cost in a
year plus keynote talks on building
digital assets and multiple income
streams digitally go now to be
quick because this isn't usually free
it's all at bit.ly Rob toolkit and you
will then be directed to the disruptors
podcast plus all this great info will
help you destroy people with logic and
facts
I give up
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is one
of our favorite comedians here in the UK
Tom stayed welcome to trigonometry thank
you Constantine thank you Francis
what what qualifies you to be here no um
no man it's really great to have you on
uh we obviously know exactly who you are
but there'll be a lot of people in our
audience who also know who you are and a
lot who don't so who are you what's been
your journey through life how are you
here Tom okay well we'll start I'll try
and sum it up pretty quick man it was uh
I was a comedian in Canada
uh started out in 1989 in a little place
called punchlines gas town which wasn't
there
um from there I uh I worked my way up
doing TV shows and all that sort of
stuff in in Canada whatever
um whatever TV shows were there whatever
kind of show business was there and um
I think in the late 90s after we went to
LA and did a whole bunch of stuff there
I was invited to come to the UK with a
friend and
um
I did a couple of guest spots in the UK
and believe me the UK was not on my
radar at that time and uh and then
I came home uh and I remember when was 9
11 whenever 9 11 was because I came home
and uh I got a
after doing the junglers I don't know
used to be a big yeah uh change his name
but I mean what a great train it was
like it was awesome
and then uh yeah and then I came back to
Canada and I got this um
email with just boom lots of work and
and the lucky part was is my uh lovely
lady Trudy uh turns out she was a
British citizen which I did not know at
the time just so everybody for the
record and I did not marry into this
country but
she uh she goes uh Tom you know my
parents are English and I was like oh
God I thought they were Newfie and uh
and and so she said well why don't we go
over for a year let's just go over for a
year and
see what happens and then next thing you
know we got over here uh all of a sudden
the TV shows came The Comedy Store I
think was the very first one and so we
did about four or five of those and then
we did oh God I can't remember but uh
the guy that represented uh Bruce Force
I think of Ian somebody he had a bunch
of shows and then and then we did uh
live at the Apollo
um probably most for your viewers uh we
did a joke no not live at the Apollo
um Michael McIntyre's Road show right
and we did the very first one of those
and I did a joke called the meat van on
there and that just went
ballistic like I've never seen
it was like writing a hit song and then
we did and then you did the Apollo and
that went really well and then we did
the Apollo and then and then a couple
little things after that and
um yeah and then and then pretty much
I'm now just here as a fixture because
uh I've decided to make this place my
home how's that yeah
15 specials deep now this stuff we want
to ask you about which we'll get into
later but uh actually before we started
you were talking about live at the
Apollo and you were saying doing live at
the Apollo in those days just change
your life right yeah that's how
significant it was yeah
um when when before because I don't
think all of this stuff was happening
when we did and I I always I always
think like I'm always that last guy
through the Stargate before it closes
you know what I mean and so I I hopped
through the Stargate and and like that
was a time where you could uh probably
it would be the equivalent of going
viral back then do you know what I mean
because the Apollo was the only show
that was out there and and Michael
McIntyre was just on his on his ride up
and now
um the Apollo is is pretty much
you know I I don't know this for sure
okay everything that I say is only an
opinion but the Apollo now is more of a
way it's more of a thing on your resume
than it is a uh Pinnacle yes you know
like so and and the um and and and I
think it's
um one of these closed clubs you know I
I remember uh there's a guy named
Anthony
um who's the producer there and I I saw
him at the Loft Bar one time and it was
it was very funny to ask him to go so
what am I getting on the Apollo again
and he said well I don't think that's
going to happen
we got a lot of box taking exercises
going on there and I was I was really
shocked to hear that do you know what I
mean because I you know I'm all for
diversity but diversity also has to have
that talent to it you know what I mean
and I think um and this is there's no
criticism to anyone but again if we're
talking about old days till now yeah you
know I feel that you know you're you're
they always said it took 10 years to
become a comedian but thanks to the
internet and and all that sort of stuff
that time scale is now gone down to like
I I see people on the Apollo that have
been there's a kid that I know that I'm
not going to mention it's only been
doing it three years and he's going to
be on the next episode which is
fantastic you know what I mean I've got
no
malice or anything like that but I'm
like wow it just shows you how the times
have changed how the how the industry
has changed I mean uh you you hear of
people going on shows because they have
more followers than the TV show would
have viewers I don't know if that's true
but it rings true to me yeah do you know
what I mean so it yeah to to to say to
be on the Apollo Now isn't the same I
think I think a Netflix special is
probably would be the equivalent of what
the Apollo used to be you know because
also you're living in a world where you
can go Global just like that you know
what I mean and that is unheard of man
for me that is like one of those things
that all of a sudden you know like you
got Danny Sloss who's uh who is just
this kid all of a sudden one Netflix
special he's selling out in Texas for
crying out loud so how great is that you
know what I mean so there's opportunity
to be had there and
um
you know you got to kind of roll with
these changes you can't um you know you
can't
criticize you can you can try and
understand them but you can't criticize
them because they're actually happening
and if you can't move with those times
then you know you're like a you're like
a jungler's comedian who's now not a
comedian because he he could only do the
John Lewis model do
I I it's interesting what you're talking
about because to me I'm going to
criticize it because
um comedians hate me and I hate them
but uh
for me like that kid three look you
can't blame the kid for taking the
opportunity let's get that straight if
any one of us had been offered that we
would have gone for it best of luck to
whoever that kid is
but you're not telling me at after three
years of gigging he has got the chops to
play that room well there's the
double-edged sword Francis I mean okay
we're living in a world where two minute
bit is worth more than an hour do you
know what I mean yeah so so this anybody
can stumble on a two-minute awesome bet
anyone can stumble on a two-minute
awesome bit anyone can put that on the
internet and all of a sudden now you
once you have that Target on your back
there's where the the other side of what
you're saying is is that oh this kid is
really good now will he be able to that
two minutes now has to become an hour do
you know what I mean so I understand
what you're saying completely I mean is
this kid is this kid whoever he is a
natural or did he luck out and because
once you get that exposure you know it
could be the death of you too man you
know that's I I I I totally see exactly
what you're saying and I agree with it
but that again that's the world that
we're in right now to to be able to at
least have that opportunity to fail or
die
in such a short amount of time yeah and
it just seems to me and and again this
is just my perspective to me like the
people who pick that kid aren't
respecting the art form
because I would say it takes
he's angry mate I don't know why I've
told him to go to therapy I've done
everything for him
in the class in a second okay yeah tell
me what you're saying
but look to me it's they're not
respecting the art form because to me it
takes at least 10 years to become to
become who must be the kid though this
is the thing like the the kid was chosen
because we're now in the internet World
it wasn't the kid the kids just putting
out a tick tock video the kids just
putting out an Instagram video the kids
just taping his show on his iPhone at
the monkey Barrel he did he's he's doing
a bit in his car about eyebrows do you
know what I mean like and like so it's
the the the people that are picking him
if you're talking about like industry
and that sort of stuff well you know the
industry isn't picking Tick-Tock people
the industry is a very tight uh closed
business man you're either these guys is
fresh if you're not friends with Daryl
Brown mine or one of these guys you're
not going anywhere man you know what I
mean if you're not friends with Jimmy
Carr you're not going anywhere you're
like that's how tight this business is
so again I want to use the double edged
sword he this kid whoever's got the two
minutes at least
bypasses that oh right yeah that Circle
you didn't have to try and get in there
no he didn't have that option so I agree
with you there's a tremendous amount of
opportunity right now as well I don't
think life of the Apollo is the
opportunity by the way because I I know
people have done it uh who again they
were less experienced than perhaps they
would have wanted to be and they got I
don't know a thousand Twitter followers
off the back of it it's it's not it's
not life-changing anymore that's why I
try not to talk about it really because
I don't think it's worth the discussion
no what I do find interesting though Tom
is a friend of mine a mutual friend of
us actually another comic went to see
your show in Edinburgh which is just
finished right and he messaged me after
going I I think Tom's had enough of this
[ __ ] and I don't know what [ __ ] he was
talking about exactly but I was curious
hmm
yeah I've uh I I uh I I threw out every
rule in the book is what what I've done
I've just I got tired of listening to
people going well you can't punch up and
you can't punch down and you know that's
a hack premise or that's a dick joke or
whatever and I was like you know what
you know if they're you're now deciding
what the masses want you know what I
mean you you're saying that we can't
talk about this or this subject is off
topic or whatever or you're gonna get
canceled there's so much just fear about
about what kind of material you're going
to do you know what I mean and and I've
just gone to the point well you know
what I'm gonna take everything
Everybody's scared of saying and I'm
gonna Chuck it right in their face and
so
um I just I just decided you know give
me a dick joke I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
it like Mike Wilmot I'm gonna I'm gonna
throw it out there you want you want an
airplane joke Here Comes an airplane
joke you want me to talk like Dave
Chappelle to tell you like it is I'll
tell you like it is you know what I mean
and I just I just felt that you know
instead of trying to fit this mold you
should I I just decided you know what
I'm gonna be an all-around comedian and
not really listen to my peers anymore
because I don't think they know what
they're saying I think they've uh they
they they've gotten to a point where
they're not themselves anymore they're
just trying to appease an audience you
know I mean not even an audience more
their own peers you know to because
they're so afraid to look stupid or
whatever you know what I mean so to to
me I've just I I I've uh I've gotten to
the point where I will just do
any type of material out there to the
best of my ability and I love my
strap-on joke
[ __ ] killer joke and I've also got it
I've also got a killer transgender you
know what I mean and and and that's
where I'm at right now I'm just I'm I'm
just decided you know no more peers if I
some search interrupt I'm just curious
can you talk about fear you talk about
having a mold and these are all things
points that I I would have pointed out
in the past and and the reaction always
is you're making it up until [ __ ] no
one's afraid to no one's self-censoring
and comedy no one's not saying would
like but you I hear what out of you is
that you think people are doing this and
you think they're doing it because
they're worried about what other
comedians yes you think that's what it
is I'm positive that's what it is man to
be able to to go up on stage and um
and to you know I don't know dude
say you thought of something funny but
you thought oh God you know what's
[ __ ] Jeff norcott gonna say or what
this guy gonna say because you know
you're you're living again if I can go
back you're living in a rule in a in a
world where there's now rules of Comedy
which comedy was there to break all
those rules do you know what I mean and
and we've just gotten so far to to what
you can say and what you can't say and
and then once you once you break out of
that and realize you know
um you're there to do a job and the
people that will like you will stay and
the people that don't like you that will
stay and you know what my peers
you know if you like if they're in the
same boat as me on that one I'm going if
you like it hang out with me if you
don't don't hang out with me but I will
I'm not going to uh sit there and and
and be in this box that you guys are
trying to keep me in now and and my
first thing was I want to tell every
dick joke I want to tell every happy
[ __ ] premise I want to do everything
that will scare the [ __ ] out of you but
that audience will [ __ ] die laughing
because you gotta understand that you
know we've been
how can I say this we've been dying out
on caviar every [ __ ] day lately I
want a McDonald's burger you know what I
mean I'm getting tired of the snails man
the snails is a good metaphor
which country the comedy culture was
completely different and the like you
said uh in sort of 2000 2001. it was
completely different
what was it like then and what how when
did you notice the change when did you
notice this kind of more let's call it
Orthodox way of thinking
okay I think that that all came when the
okay that all came when the social media
bubble showed up
once you started all of a sudden seeing
all these clips of all these other
comedians out there and I know I know a
lot of comedians sit there and go I
don't watch other comedians right I
don't watch other people's [ __ ]
specials because I don't want to step on
anybody's thing but it's impossible not
to yeah you know and
and the problem was is back then you you
didn't watch a lot of people's specials
back then you watched who you were on
with and all that sort of stuff but now
now the problem is is that you do have
all these comedians it's like
it's kind of like the way a high school
girl would flip through Cosmo magazine
you know now you're you are living in
this world where you're trying to
compete with impossible standards
because how can you not watch every
every comedian putting his thing on the
thing how can you not watch that and not
compare yourself to it you know what I
mean and you feel like that fat little
girl reading Cosmopolitan going I can
never achieve this stuff but yet you
still try which makes you in a way a bit
of a phony because you don't believe in
yourself you know what I mean so I think
that back then you had no choice to
believe in yourself and and and that's
where the comedy came from and now
you're sitting there you're trying to
compete with the rest of the world which
is just an impossible [ __ ] task man
and it puts and it puts a lot of
puts a lot of pressure on you and so
when you say What's the difference the
difference is is that it's hard to
believe in yourself when you have all
this other stuff going on and you're
trying to compete so you're you're
trying to you know
um just stay in a certain line of a
certain topic you know or or whatever
where I don't think you had that back in
in 2001 2002 definitely didn't have it
in the 80s definitely didn't have it in
the 90s you know what I mean but but
come 2010 man it was like you know
everybody's just that you know fat
little girl watching supermodels on TV
all the time and just sort of going I
want to be like her instead of wanting
to be you
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousand thousands of pounds
in legal fees the great thing about
expressvpn is that you don't need any
technical skills to set up just like
Francis fire up the app and it's one
button to connect One Tap on a button
was all it needed for my entire life to
disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
when did you feel like things started to
change with you know what was acceptable
to say or the correct way to to oh like
the death of the sexual assault jokes
and yeah rape jokes yeah and all of that
sort of stuff because I remember when I
started in 2009 it was like if you
didn't have one if you didn't have a
rape joke it was like what's wrong with
you yeah yeah yeah no we're all doing it
like what was and then suddenly
um you know that's a real tough one for
me to answer Francis and it's not that
I'm a fear of it because when I think of
that I I think of book burning when I
when I when you're talking about the
what when the when the what you can say
and what you can't say came in okay and
is that what we're talking about just so
I make sure
um uh the when all of a sudden that
ain't funny anymore that ain't it again
that goes where Society went all of a
sudden you're seeing all that stuff on
TV for real it isn't just a joke anymore
it's like it's like proper real stuff
going on but in in its defense and I
really mean this and this is coming from
my mother of all people uh it's like
Footloose you know what I mean yeah
whether you can't tell rape jokes around
here no more hey boy watch yourself you
know there's a town dancing and not
saying that it is cool but my mom said
it the best anytime you can't show the
absurdity of it anytime you can because
that's all they were like everybody
think and for this word joke is an
interesting thing do you know what I
mean because these subjects aren't jokes
do you know what I mean a joke to me is
two guys walk into a bar that is and you
put that beside any of those words all
of a sudden yeah it cheapens this out
but if you're sitting there going I want
to show you the absurdity of this this
topic and that's what most really great
comedians can do from George Carlin but
but the problem is is that the word joke
just just takes it out you know what I
mean and and so the problem is is once
you hide all these jokes away you know
what I mean you put them in the dark
they just grow stronger and stronger and
stronger and the only way to to actually
um uh bring you gotta shine some light
on them and put some clown on that clown
shoes and and clown nose on that
nightmare of a thing to show that it's
the absurdity so in in actual fact by
not talking about it and and being
showing the absurdity behind it you know
you you you actually probably influence
more people to do it do you know what I
mean because there's you don't talk
about it for the Ridiculousness that it
is man that
I started probably a little bit later in
like 2014 I think you could have started
doing stand-up then and by that point
you wouldn't have heard anyone doing a
rape joke on the circuit and I don't
feel like my life is poor or for it I I
I'm not sitting there go oh my God you
know we lost the great material about
rape like I agree that wasn't a thing
that I felt not defending no no no none
of us are I'm just I'm trying to also
protect you a little bit because there
there'll be people watching of course
there will yeah this is where Jeff said
I've lost it that's my opinion yeah this
is what he was saying I I you know what
no it's fine if you don't want to hear
it but yeah I yeah and so I I want to
protect you a little bit because I I
think what you're talking about is it's
important not to have rules in comedy so
people can be free to be creative but
that often gets misinterpreted
deliberately by people who want to
disagree with us as
we don't want to have rules in comedy
because you want to do an hour set about
rape no that that that's ridiculous I
know but that but that is the way that
people mischaracterize these things
sometimes so uh but the freedom that
you're talking about
um you know before the social media
comes in it's fascinating because it's I
think it's really interesting that
comedians are self-censoring
they are to protect themselves from
their opinions of other comedians given
the fact that that's not uh that's not
who we're playing to no just as a
comedian or as a YouTube show host or
podcast or whatever we're playing to the
people watching this right that's our
job it's not our job to be liked by
other Comedians and yet that seems to be
according to you at least the direction
that it's gone in of course I I I
believe that again I want to say any one
of my opinions can change I'm old enough
to know to not stick but for now
for where I'm at that's how I feel until
somebody comes along and explains it a
different way to me and can go oh I I
totally can see that I'm not inflexible
on any of these things but yes I I do
agree because uh you live and most of
the comedians live in a this this world
called cancel culture which is such a
new it's a new thing too do you know
what I mean like just one joke I mean uh
that can change all of a sudden this
whole body of work you do one joke and
all of a sudden wipe all that stuff out
a bar of course illegal activity of yeah
any kind you know what I mean that that
is that's a whole different thing but
I'm what I'm talking about is oh so you
made an attempt at
um doing something a little bit more
risque a little bit more dangerous and
that's why you're you're seeing
comedians now asking people not to bring
their cameras in on on a working night
where you're trying to work out stuff
and I mean that's that's where we're at
now that again that just shows the fear
of everything and then and it's like
um it's like people just do how can I
say a paycheck comedy I guess paycheck
comedy would be the best way to do it
where you're you're you're you're you're
really writing things that uh are there
not to offend anyone do you know what I
mean and that's where me and Patrice
O'Neill
would agree that that just isn't comedy
that's selling products do you know what
I mean like you you if you pleased
everybody in that audience you know what
I mean then I've also got this for sale
sponsored by yeah you know and whereas
the best comedy that you ever had you
know there's people walking out going I
can't believe he said that you know but
again we're back to
um being subjective and all that do you
think Society has changed as well though
because because I guess uh I think part
of the reason is 20 years ago people
would walk out of a comedy club and
they'd be like I can't believe he said
that yeah let's go for a pine whereas
now it's like I can't believe he said
that let's go on social media
what do you want me to say after that
because that's exactly what happens man
that is that is exactly you your stupid
ass opinion now can be translated to the
world to be part of the content
pollution that is out there do you know
what I mean like it's it's just it's
amazing but back in the day like I I
wholeheartedly agree with you I don't
know how I can add to what you're about
to say because you're right you would
walk out and the most people you could
talk to was seven or eight guys and and
four of them would go shut up and quit
being such a [ __ ] weenie man it's
just a [ __ ] comedy show you know what
I mean like [ __ ] if you don't like
them don't go and [ __ ] see them how
about that man but you're right now
[ __ ] you don't like a comedy show oh
my God here comes a Facebook post here
comes uh block I gotta block you now I
gotta do all of that sort of TripAdvisor
TripAdvisor four-star commit three and a
half star comedian Yeah man so I I don't
know how I can I I'm only gonna agree
with you on that one good that's what I
like you just do that that's fine I
can't I don't want to argue that point
because it's very valid and and like I
said this
how do you change with this world being
the dinosaur that I am do you know what
I mean it's like
what [ __ ] truly said it the best it's
like every time you go on stage it's
like watching a 90s comedian do a guest
spot
when she saw Rick Astley on the Foo
Fighters she goes that's you
and I'm like well welcome to Jurassic
Park
you know yes so that's yeah yeah it's
just the whole scene has just changed so
the real question is is is is okay is
this the the pendulum always swings too
far one way do you know what I mean yes
and and if if you're a Buddhist or any
of those things you know nothing stays
the same so for what I what I like what
I would like to think
is that even though we are in this world
we even though we're in this world of
um you know and before I even say this I
also don't give credit to the comedians
that aren't playing that part do you
know what I mean because there's a lot
of young comedians out there I don't
want to brush them all on the same
because there are some really great
young comedians that are also in my boat
going [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm not dealing
with that you know what I mean I'm not
doing that so I don't want to do it all
to go but it is safer going the other
Road you know and but
um there's going to be a backlash to
whatever's going on right now do you
know what I mean you can't you can't not
think that what it's just gonna keep on
going that way you know what I mean
because people will eventually get bored
of it and you know who the people will
be the next Generation because I also
feel
I also feel that every generate my
church this is the backlash to my
generation do you know what I mean this
is I don't actually explain well for all
the times you know like
um
when you for all the things we were
talking about the the kids have to talk
about something different do you know
what I mean to make a name for
themselves this is a man who's the
father of the two kids in their 20s yeah
fortunately I didn't get that back
but I I think the comedians like the um
oh who would I saying the bo burnhams
maybe or whatever
um they're they're the backlash to our
our thing like because you have to how
how are you gonna be the same as your
dad do you know what I mean you have to
do the exact opposite of your dad just
to get noticed so I think that also
plays a big part in what's going on
nowadays because you know whereas we
grew up on Richard Pryor and all those
guys and whatever Billy Conley for this
country yeah for us it was Colin and
Hicks and people like that yeah of
course okay okay but for the average
viewer they every time I say Carlin they
don't know who the [ __ ] he is out in the
UK and I'm like what which also shows
you that he didn't even the greatest
comedian didn't really even go Global
man whereas uh you know Ali Wong
everybody knows you know nothing against
Ally one I'm just we're just talking
about the the uh oh God I hate when I
lose words but the
advertisement something in that room
yeah
she's her PR yeah [ __ ] crazy whereas
George Carlin you know stayed in America
but it was great
um uh the backlash to them was like well
they were the backlash to the Bob
newharts and all that sort of stuff and
then for the longest time it was there
and then then we got to evening at The
Improv I don't know if you ever remember
that show and then all of a sudden it
started to become a little more TV clean
which is where we showed up you know
what I mean we still wanted to be like
them but you know
um and then all of a sudden we probably
took it maybe a little too far to go
back to the the yeah the no the the
topics
we maybe we maybe did take it a little
too far because you can only bring that
so far too and I think and then then
these guys go well you know I'm just
going to be the cleanest this comic that
ever was and be able to do all this sort
of stuff but what I'm trying to say is
eventually that the the next generation
of comedians will be bored of that and
will probably go back to where we are
Tommy maybe it's such a good point and
maybe that will happen I mean you were
involved in not not a cancellation but
you used to write jokes for Frankie
Boyle show tremored all night and that
had its own share of scandals I remember
one that went all over the newspaper
banned this film Etc so what was it like
to be in the center of that
um the you're talking the Tramadol
nights yeah
that was that was probably the I would
attribute that to the beginning of it
when it was him and Katie Price had the
art I know what you're talking about
explain it to the uh Frankie Boyle
believe it or not if you don't know who
he is very he loves he's one of the last
loves uh just saying things for you know
he's a very intelligent man very
intelligent man very great joke writer
but he's he's definitely not afraid of
backlash in any I remember him actually
telling me conflict is better than
agreement you know what I mean
especially in conflict because if you're
doing comedy and you know you just walk
out and go ah that was a nice show
you're gonna forget about the dude but
if you again you go out and go all of a
sudden conflict you remember the
person's name right so he did a joke
obviously about Harvey
[Applause]
cage fighter
coming strong enough to stop Harvey from
[ __ ] up
[Applause]
obviously
ridiculous but you also have a Fame
hungry monster on the other side named
Katie Price who saw an opportunity to go
oh my God this will put me in the papers
because I don't I don't know her
personally or anything like that but I
people's actions speak louder than words
and if you want to debate me on Katie
Price's actions over her lifetime I
think she's a bit of a Fame hungry
monster
a bit of an attention see a bit of an
attention seeker and and normally a joke
like that would have just flown by for
Frankie but he caught the attention of
this and all of a sudden that became one
of the biggest stories of that time and
I think it ignited the wow actually I've
never thought about that until just now
so here's my first opinion on it before
it gets changed through the years is I
think that would have been one of the
first times that people saw that you
could get outraged at a joke and stop
something
because after that they canceled this
wonderful dark show that was just
getting its foot I'm not saying it was
the greatest do you know what I mean I'm
not saying that Tramadol mites was the
greatest
show ever but it did it had the
potential to be like like the next uh
young ones or whatever the because the
sketches were just outrageous you know
Jim Muir um I can't even remember the
other dude which is bad but Jim Muir in
this very talented I think he was
burniston's burniston guy he was in with
him and then Frankie and me and and and
it had the potential to be this
wonderful
offensive uh taboo kind of you know all
right let's close the curtains and watch
this
smoke a big joint you know
um but she was really I can't think of
anyone before that who attacked a joke
so I think that might have if if I could
throw in my how many marbles are in the
jar Theory I think that might have been
one of the first uh outrage
um uh to show people that oh if I get
really offended at a joke I can actually
do something about it you know so the
show get canceled it got canceled
because of that man they they she sued
she's I I don't know all the details
because when you got a show like that
the one thing about it is that Frankie's
the head yeah you know what I mean I'm
not the hit they're not coming after me
and they're not going after gym and
they're not going after a burniston guy
um they're going after Frankie do you
know what I mean and I think she's she
was going to sue them and and you know
when you got Executives going well I
don't need this kind of hassle [ __ ]
bend you know but in a way it also
helped because Tramadol Knights became
like a little one season cult uh a show
that that's that's just out there with
some really shitty sketches like really
actually a former guest of the show the
other day and for an unrelated reason
sent me a clip from that which is the
professor who
wanked he wanks himself back in time
so it was of its time
takes his students back in time and only
half of them come back because anyway
so funny but again sort of of its time
too yeah yeah yeah well is it really
though like I mean some of the sketches
I think some of them will
I mean come on man just a kid jerking
Jesus off on the cross uh to get back to
like [ __ ] his glory to get back to
Time Was
I mean it's so outrageous it's
ridiculous that anyone who took it
seriously you know what I mean I I don't
know what to say to you yeah but but
yeah definitely I oh my God I haven't
thought about that in years
I remember that sorry no no yes I think
the to the point of
yeah I think that might have sparked off
the outright the offensive uh culture
that that came after that for this
country I don't know what was going on
in Canada or I don't think the Frankie
Boyle Katie Price fight hit Canada but
it definitely hit here because then
you'd have all the stars like the the
whatever what's her name Cheryl who's
who's Sir Cole and all that getting
involved and going yeah you shouldn't
bring people's kids into this you
shouldn't do this and you shouldn't do
that and then all of a sudden the debate
was created uh and the show got canceled
but uh Katie got more famous and Frankie
got more famous so in a way they
mutually helped each other but in a way
they might have
started the the outrage the the offense
uh you can do something about it uh at
the time so we're living in and do you
just I'm not sure I believe that but it
sounds really good
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
this sort of throw some food off and
then just bought questions at them
before they can escape uh not the
American ones as they have guns and
you'd have to be extra careful with the
females as that's how I got in trouble
last time do you really imagine you're
gonna get Douglas Murray near the frozen
food aisle if you want to ask our
incredible guest questions and have
access to phenomenal behind the scenes
content then you have to be on our
locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
Tom do you and do you find yourself did
you find yourself after that
self-censoring more and more with your
material
um
not really because again I wasn't in the
thing and and I'm not I'm not an
offensive comedian Francis that like do
you know what I mean
I can write offensive jokes which are
brilliant you know generally one of my
favorite Comics I mean I've seen you go
on stage Tom yeah and talk about say are
there any men here in their 50s yeah are
there any men here in their 50s with an
18 year old daughter and they went yeah
anyway do you ever sometimes look at
their friends
and look I was emcee at that gig I was
in the back dying with laughter everyone
was dying with laughter there were there
were a few women who maybe didn't
appreciated of course there were man but
my daughter liked that joke so let's
just say that right now my daughter was
the one that said I remember having to I
remember having I do I wanted to use a
funny name I wanted to use a funny name
and I kept trying to think of all her
friends and natalica was the funniest
because it just had that to it you know
what I mean yeah yeah
it's funny you say that because I'm also
the person that wrote meat van which is
the least offensive but I mean I don't
want to be a Dave Chappelle and I don't
want to be a bill Burrs or these guys
and they're all great you know what I
mean but I want to be like well-rounded
you know I want to be able to step on
both sides of the fence I want to be
able to say you know what I got a kids
show coming up you know I want to go in
and I want to I don't want to tell them
about
finding your daughter's friend you're
not allowed to find your daughters sexy
of you know it's just it's just one of
those things that you I don't want to uh
pigeonhole
who I am do you know what I mean I don't
want to be known as an offensive
comedian because that's just that's just
wrong you know what I mean I want to be
known as a guy who could tell an
offensive joke ooh Tom's told something
a little risque but uh he's also you
know he's also talked about Argos for
crying out loud man you know so but I
don't mind where we're talking about
Francis is I don't mind going there yeah
that's what you're saying I don't mind
going there but I definitely don't want
to be labeled oh here comes Tom the
offensive comedian I don't want that
either you know what I mean I want him
to go oh man that guy had a like there
was something for everybody in there man
but to me that marks out the Best
comedian so if you think about Bill
Hicks everyone always remembers his
political bits but he also remembered a
bit about the Gideon Bible like who are
The Gideons you've never seen one never
met one yet they're all over the [ __ ]
world like it's a great bit of
observation material of course you know
and to me those are the best comedians I
think that now this kind of need to
categorize everybody
kind of the means the art form reduces
it you know what what is offensive to
one it's not offensive to another you
gotta that there's the there's the you
the word subjective man is so prominent
in art
there is no come on man of course you
talk about Bill Hicks I can remember the
first time I saw him wasn't even on it
was on Rodney Dangerfield special I was
in a town so small in a hotel I dialed
nine and I got the Elmer Dinkley
residence do you remember that one do
you know that one you see so you're
right he does and then all of a sudden
he launches into advertisement you know
so he does he does have that range to
him that he could do but the more he
does one thing more people want that
thing and it's hard for him to stay true
to you know you can't just launch out on
an attack on Advertising I see what
you're saying Bill no you don't get what
I'm saying oh that's the angle there I
don't say what to say and and then him
going so I was in a hotel so small right
after that it's Gotta you know so maybe
you grow into who you are you know you
give the people what they want and I'm
not sure if that's the way I would like
to go you know what I mean I don't want
to just like you say go hey there's oh
people really like that I should do more
of that I know I gotta stay true too
um
yeah stay true to all all aspects it's
it's good to be able to write all
different kinds of jokes Everybody Must
agree on that man you know what I mean
and and I'm I'm pretty sure even these
the one thing I do know about comedians
even these young ones they do have dark
jokes yeah but they just won't tell them
on stage they'll tell them at the table
in the comedy club Corner man I just I
don't understand
that's kind of one of the funny things
to to me in Francis because we get
criticized by comedians a lot for the
things that we say
and yet we're only saying the exact same
things they're saying in the car on the
way home yeah you know what I mean of
course you do but of course I do that's
all that we're saying and nothing more
but listen coming back to Edinburgh and
coming back to you we're talking about
you know you wanna I I actually I
suspect that what you're really talking
about is you want to be authentic to who
Tom stayed if you want to be you rather
than trying to be somebody else to let
the audience guide you in what kind of
material you're gonna do yeah yeah what
I find weird though is uh obviously
while you were in Edinburgh Jerry
sadowitz his show gets pulled and I'm
going like if you've seen Jerry sadowitz
ever if you've read the title of a show
if you've read the promo like you cannot
possibly be under any illusions that
this is a guy who's deliberately
offensive and that's the act right it's
the act and yet even that like he does
everything he can to make sure people
and understand I'm an offensive comedian
his show is called not for anyone I I
don't you can get clear on that and yet
somehow people still will come to his
show they'll get upset they'll complain
to The Venue maybe it was the staff at
the venue I suspect that complained oh I
got yeah I can tell oh oh oh dude uh
before we go into that yeah the staff I
when I was on my last tour uh I played a
place called the Glee Club and I used uh
I used the word appropriately I use the
word gay and [ __ ] just because it's
from but in context yes of course do you
know what I mean I would never not going
out on the street in the you know
whatever this
um and yeah I had start the staff
complained so now and the next day they
said Tom can do not use those uh two
words uh on tonight's show because
whatever we're
um
lgbtq friendly here and I'm like
are you kidding me you think I'm not I'm
my daughter's a dancer you know what I
mean are you [ __ ] out of your [ __ ]
mind I've been to parties with two kids
that were breaking up talking to these
two boys going you're meant for each
other man what are you doing you know
what I mean like like just because you
your your topics or whatever it doesn't
what you think what do you think
you're out of your [ __ ] mind man but
with Jerry Jerry was an interesting one
over the festival because
yes he is offensive there's no doubt
about it there's not what what you said
not for anyone perfect title
everything's said but uh what what I
what was I heard was it got into the
racial hatred
area you know what I mean and and and
I'm glad Jerry's out there because
personally I again I don't think
uh he would match that uh that I don't
think Jerry's a racist in any way from
the men that I know and all that sort of
stuff but because he's so offensive he I
think you want to go there do you know
what I mean you want to at least talk
about it in your own way create the
absurdity that it is but I wasn't at the
show so I only got drips and drabs of
what happened but in a way again with
with a guy like Jerry
to be banned
to be banned is kind of what he wants do
you know what I mean to be banned from
what I heard from them Banning him and
he only had two shows anyway it's like
let's not let's not think that oh my God
Jerry's been bad for the whole run how
will he ever he only had two shows the
first one
and after he got banned his actual tour
sold out man because because you're
right if you're going to Jerry's
sandwich and thinking that over all the
this man has cultivated uh of trying to
offend you from day [ __ ] week up
punched out in Montreal I believe for
saying moose [ __ ] and oh the Canadians
were outraged and I'm like that's not
the half of it man and for him to get
banned at the presence and listen to We
don't condone this kind of art form from
whoever the I can't remember what the
owner said we we don't support that kind
of can I interrupt you that because it's
important moment right they didn't
actually say we don't support this kind
of material do you know what they said
tell me we don't feel we don't support
the opinions Jerry sadowicz expressed on
stage yeah oh that's the opinions right
so your comedy Act is now your opinions
yes
yes how the [ __ ] does that work well it
obviously works because they said it
they don't know how because it seems a
little bit ridiculous but anyway sorry I
interrupted you so your point you're
making is it's to his benefit which
thank [ __ ] by the way that it is it
should be to as bad yeah if you try to
cancel Jerry he's one of those guys if
you try to cancel them you'll only make
them bigger yeah you know if you really
wanted to hurt them you should have
ignored it yeah you should have just
[ __ ] ignored it and said only one
more show let him get him out of here
and then he's gone yeah but what you did
was yeah you you you made them you made
them more popular than ever now all the
racists are gonna come this you know
he's gonna be like you know I got the
gay pink dollar I got the racist dollars
coming in you know yeah so uh yeah if to
me that was a lot of people said that
was the death of the festival because as
because if it can happen
to him imagine what they can do to
comedians that wouldn't survive it yes
do you know what I mean that's the real
scary point on that do you agree with
that yeah of course I do man because now
now you can there's this under again
another underlying
fear you have to worry about out there
is the oh my God if I say one wrong
thing if the if I offend the the
bartender or whatever and I get uh
whatever coming back
I could lose my run now and and and I'm
and and and if I'm not as as big as
Jerry is and that you're actually you
could have your
there was what was that there was a kid
a lad kid a little while back that they
got really mad at that it actually did
happen too and I don't know if you
remember he was he was doing lad yes
Dapper laughs man
he's the opposite end of that yeah he
got banned and then his career just went
down the [ __ ] tubes man from the
festival so that perhapses that's right
man so he's the opposite he's something
that could happen because they were they
were what you said they were putting his
opinions this is a character he's doing
but people uh decided that those were
his opinions and boom gone you know what
I mean so he didn't have the same
strength as Jerry to to rise up to it
you know because Jerry had the the
people to go like you're saying that are
you know of course Jerry's offensive
he's he's the most offensive commit what
do you think you're not going to see an
offensive comedian man
[Laughter]
and Dapper was the opposite of that man
he got he got hammered and and we've
never seen him since man we've never
seen him since and he was just doing a
character on what whether you like like
it or not his character was pretty spot
on of what goes on out there you know
yeah Tom
do you ever worry about comedy the way
it's going and like you seeing these
things happen or do you have faith like
you said that it will swing back I have
faced that little swing back Francis I I
uh you know because here's the other
thing if I was if I was 20 years old
this is my starting point do you know
what I mean and how do you know that
these kids the these these new comedians
they're just early on in their career
you know what I mean maybe they'll be
looking at it going I can't believe I
did that [ __ ] you know what I mean like
every other comedian looks back on their
material and goes oh God I'm embarrassed
that I even did that and changed because
every comedian has an ark to them do you
know what I mean some of them don't and
they don't go anywhere but the real good
ones have a nice Arc to them that will
change and and I think
uh yeah I do think that that comedy uh
goes through periods do you know what I
mean and this is just where we are and
we can talk about it like we're doing
right now we can we can complain about
we can show its merits we can show its
faults you know and but and for us it's
scary because it's not a world we know
do you know what I mean it's like it's
this whole new everything we know is
slowly slipping away and now I'm you
know try I have to find my place in it
without changing who I am you know what
I mean and that's a very tough uh route
to go down you know but I'm gonna have
to do it or I fade away you know what I
mean like I just got on Tick Tock for
[ __ ] sakes
and I'm like oh my God I got 174
000 views on something and my endorphin
levels went up through the roof so in a
way to me you know as much as I don't
like it I can I also find it a really
good tool for me too you know what I
mean because because they're you still
got to remember there's enough of us
there's enough of my generation to fight
off this generation right you know like
uh you know there's there's enough of of
50 year olds and that that love that
think it's [ __ ] that [ __ ] hate it
[ __ ] hate it and they want you know
that's they want the Dave Chappelle talk
about transgender you know whereas you
know and you could see the push and if I
could use that as a nice example you can
see the pushback you know like again but
it takes a strong comedian like that to
lead the charge in in something so
you've got the younger ones that are
fighting them this way but you also got
his fans are going shut the [ __ ] up and
and but again just that's the change I'm
we're moving through for me like I can't
not deny it isn't happening I can't bury
my head in this and and and I and I can
also just see them even though I may not
like it I can also see them as tools and
how can I use these tools to inject my
kind of comedy in there like throw a
little you know wood shoe in the clog
and and maybe maybe influence one of
these younger comedians to be uh you
know to not I don't want to say be like
please
so bad but but to show them another way
yes you know yeah maybe maybe well it's
a nice positive note on which to wrap up
Tom it's been a real pleasure I hope
people will come and see you I think
they've got a flavor of the stuff that
you do and you're very good comic of
course
um the last question we always ask is
always the same which is what do you
think is the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be one thing we're not talking about is
a society I think we're not talking
about the death
of the lead singer of The Tragically Hip
Gord Downey the Canadian icon that
didn't make it globally but was probably
one of the best
singers and one of the best bands in the
world that got
shoved under the carpet for some reason
and only really remained in Canada and I
think we should be talking about them
and
and letting the rest of the world
introducing them to The Tragically Hip
and and let the if we talked about it a
little more than than the world would
have one great another of the great
bands that they're missing
fantastic stuff Tom thank you so much
for coming on um so you're on Tick Tock
where else do people go to find you yeah
[Laughter]
I'm on I'm I I'm I'm reluctantly
on whatever the the tool that uh
Facebook take Tick Tock I'm known as the
commander on uh Twitter uh I got an
Instagram where somebody else said
Tom stayed so stayed.com
like just saying these things out loud
makes me feel like the hypocrite I know
that I might be but yeah we just joined
uh Tick Tock so yeah I'm pretty sure
you'd be able to find me if you really
needed to man and you're also on tour
don't forget to plug oh yeah yeah I'm on
uh def that one is one thing yeah thank
you man I'm so bad at that I am so bad
at promoting my I'm always
oh God I always sat there go you know
where to find me that was the dumbest
thing I've ever done a micro uh yeah if
you go to tomstate.com you can find uh
where I'm playing I'm coming to I think
we got about 40 50 dates all over the UK
yeah yeah and you can join the loyal
state in these fans that have uh been
with me since the beginning and I love
them all and I've partied with them all
and you if you everyone should go and
watch you because to me you're one of
the finest comedians work at the moment
I love watching your stuff oh thanks
friends man well it's the truth man he
looked at me as well waiting for me to
Yes mine as well yes I love you as well
no we're both big fans Tom make sure you
go and see him yeah and thank you for
watching and listening uh we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one oral show all of
them go out at 7 pm UK time I'm also
going to ask Tom a question from our
locals uh but if you and if you want
your trigonometry on the go uh it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
there is no way you're going to compete
with party time
I could keep up with Snoop Dogg
[Music]